>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Good morning.
You know, any time I have the
opportunity to kick off one
of these events, I
always feel a little bit
like I should apologize
for interrupting the party.
So apologies for interrupting
the party, but welcome,
welcome to the Library
of Congress.
I'm Lee Ann Potter.
I direct educational
outreach here.
And I am thrilled to welcome you
to our symposium on diversity
in children's literature,
sponsored by the library.
And, of course, We
Need Diverse Books.
This morning -- So if you want
to clap or something, feel free.
[ Applause ]
As you know, our program
really does have a title.
We're calling it Seen and
Heard: The Power of Books.
This program is being
live streamed.
So I want to give a shout out
to all of those in the audience
that are at a distance,
especially those
in time zones other than ours.
You know, it's 9 o'clock here.
There's folks in
Chicago are watching.
Albuquerque are watching.
Folks in Sacramento
are out there.
So we appreciate them
getting up for this event.
And finally, I want
to thank my colleagues
who are making that happen.
Live streams and lights
big screens don't happen
by themselves.
So thanks to my colleagues
for making things happen.
All right.
So here on Capitol Hill,
three buildings are part
of the Library of Congress.
And they are named for three
of our founding fathers.
The building that we're in
this morning is the James
Madison building.
And for those of you who came in
downstairs on our first floor,
if you had looked
over to your left,
you would have seen a
statue of James Madison.
And you if you'd walked into the
room, you could have read some
of his quotes on the walls.
They're engraved down there.
And there's one that sort
of speaks to the Library
of Congress and to cultural
institutions like the library.
And frankly, I think it sort
of speaks to today's program.
So I'm going to paraphrase
it a little bit for you.
It reads, learned institutions
ought to be favorite objects
with every free people.
They throw light
over the public mind.
I love that.
They throw light
over the public mind.
Even as Kathy and Alan
and I were first discussing
this program last summer
at the ALA conference,
I had a hunch
that this would be a
light-throwing event.
So now, I'm about to introduce
this morning's panel moderator.
But for the transition to make
any sense, you all will need
to know that when I described
the library to people
who do not know much
about it, I often talk
about it being a place
that sparks ideas.
The primary sources in the
collections: my colleagues,
the architecture of the
Thomas Jefferson building.
They all inspire creativity,
and they help us learn
and imagine possibilities.
Okay. So a minute ago, we were
talking about throwing light,
and I've just mentioned sparks.
So when Kathy asked me if I
would introduce our moderator,
naturally, I did a
little research about her.
And immediately, I
thought, wow, serendipity.
This author is perfect.
Her website has a fabulous URL.
This morning's moderator is
Linda Sue Park, L.S. Park.
And if you go to her website,
you'll find that
the URL, lspark.
Huh! Magic.
Linda was born in
Urbana, Illinois.
She grew up outside of Chicago
and earned her bachelor's degree
at Stanford University.
She is a Newberry medalist and
the author of numerous novels,
picture books, and poetry
collections for children.
Her work often uses historical
settings and innovative forms
to expand young readers'
sense of possibility.
Her poetry collection,
Tap Dancing on the Roof,
utilizes a Korean syllabic verse
form to bring surprise and humor
to everyday moments and objects.
Her novels for teenage
readers include A Single Shard,
When My Name Was Keoko,
and A Long Walk to Water,
based on a true story.
Her picture books include,
The Firekeeper's Son,
illustrated by Julie
Downing, and Bee-bim Bop,
illustrated by Ho Baek Lee.
She lives with her family
in Rochester, New York.
And I have the feeling
she is just who we need
to start throwing some light
on our program this morning.
Please join me in
welcoming Linda Sue Park.
[ Applause ]
>> Linda Sue Park: Good morning.
I am already having so much fun.
I'd like to thank the
Library of Congress,
and We Need Diverse Books, of
course, and especially Ellen O
and Caroline Richman
and Kathy Weinberg,
the Walter Awards judging panel,
and all of you for being here,
including those of you online.
I serve on the advisory board
of We Need Diverse Books.
And I'm just so thrilled
that they asked me
to be the moderator
of today's symposium.
So we have the power of books.
And I'm guessing that if you are
in this room, you have a story
or two about the power of books.
A couple of quick ones of mine.
My daughter is named
after a character in one
of Charlotte [inaudible] books.
Many years ago, I moved to
Brooklyn because of A Tree Grows
in Brooklyn, but
perhaps most important,
I survived a childhood
of being different,
in part because of the
strength books gave me.
This morning, I am delighted
to introduce the three winners
of the Walter Honor Awards,
whose work turns the power
of books into a juggernaut.
Margarita Engle is the national
young people's poet laureate
and the first Latina
to receive that honor.
She is the Cuban-American
recipient of many awards
for her verse novels,
including a Newbery honor
for The Surrender Tree,
a PEN literary award
for The Lightning
Dreamer, a Pura Belpre
and a previous Walter
honor for Enchanted Air.
And I just decided
that was enough.
I couldn't keep listing
the rest of them.
Most recently, she was named by
the United States board of books
for young people
as the US nominee
for the 2018 Astrid
Lindgren Memorial award,
and she is the author
of Forest World,
the 2018 Walter honor title
for younger readers,
Margarita Engle.
[ Applause ]
>> Mitali Perkins' novels
for young readers
include Rickshaw Girl,
a New York public library top
100 book, and Bamboo People,
an ALA top 10 [inaudible] novel.
Mitali was born in Kolkata,
India, and has lived
in Bangladesh, India,
England, Thailand,
Mexico, Cameroon and Ghana.
She currently resides
in San Francisco
where she is a lecturer at St.
Mary's College of California.
She is the author of You
Bring the Distant Near,
a 2018 Walter honor
book for older readers.
Mitali, where's Mitali?
There she is.
[ Applause ]
Francisco X. Stork is the author
of Marcelo in the Real World,
winner of the Schneider
family book award for teens,
and Once Upon a World,
and the, oh, sorry,
and the Once Upon a World
award, also the author
of The Last Summer of
the Death Warriors,
on the YALSA Best Fiction
for Teens list and winner
of the Amelia Elizabeth
Waldon Award.
He lives outside Boston, and he
is the author of Disappeared,
a 2018 Walter Honor
book for older readers.
[ Applause ]
Okay. We're going to start
with the panelists as readers.
So my first question is, I'd
like to ask them to think back
to their childhoods and where
did your books come from.
Were you public school
library attendees?
Was it school?
Was it your parents?
How did you have access
to books when you young?
So Margarita, go ahead.
>> Margarita Engle: For me,
it was the public library,
the Arroyo Seco branch
in Northeast Los Angeles.
And I would go every
Saturday and get a stack.
But I have to say that
I read more adult books
than children's books.
That's because I wanted
international books.
I wanted books about
other countries.
And at that time,
there weren't books
about other countries
for children.
So I would go in the
adult travel section,
which was illegal.
The librarians would
chase me away.
They thought I was supposed to
stay in the children's section.
But I would get anything
about geography and travel
in other countries
that I could find.
>> Linda Sue Park: Wonderful.
Mitali.
>> Mitali Perkins: Yes,
definitely the public
library in Flushing, Queens.
We immigrated -- Yes, Flushing!
So we immigrated there when I
was seven and come from a family
that is immigrant and refugee.
My parents lost everything
in the war, left Bangladesh,
arrived in Kolkata, and then
when we came to the states,
like a lot of immigrant
families, we had very little.
So no books in the home.
But my sister one day
-- I have two sisters,
Sonali, Rupali and Mitali.
We all speak Bengali.
Sonali took me by the hand and
said I have a surprise for you
because she knew I was a
reader already, took me down.
We walked ten blocks
to the Flushing branch.
And when I walked in, she said,
you can take seven books home.
And I was just is
this Ali Baba's cave.
What has happened?
So that was where
I started reading.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
I grew up in Mexico.
My mother was a single mother.
So we lived in my
grandfather's house.
And there was just one
bookcase in his bedroom.
It was like one of those
old kind of glass things.
And I knew where the
key was hidden, so.
And he had this set of volume.
I think it was like 20 volumes
called [foreign language
spoken], which was like
treasures for youth.
And it was like a compilation
of fiction, nonfiction,
you know, stories of science.
You could learn a language if
you read those things carefully.
So that's how I -- I
went through those books,
and I don't think I saw a
library until we moved to Texas
when I was nine years old.
>> Linda Sue Park:
I think about that.
I think about all the
places in the world.
And even in our country, where
young people don't have access
to a library, how do
they live, you know?
So, I mean, that's
really interesting.
Okay. Could you talk
about the first time?
And it may not have been in your
childhood, but the first time
that you felt seen in a book
or heard in a book, right.
So why don't we start at
the other end this time.
Yeah.
>> Francisco X. Stork: You know,
I grew up with this identity
of being Mexican
for a long time.
I didn't become an American
citizen till I was 26.
So it really the authors
from Latin America
that I just grew up with.
It was only when I was
in college and I realized
that now I had lived, you know,
15 years in the United States
and I had gone through learning
a new language and, you know,
getting paddled for speaking
Spanish in the playground
and getting rejected
by the beautiful Becky
because I was Mexican.
But, you know, there
were certain things
that were a little bit
different than Mexicans.
And I began to acquire
that identity.
And I think it was like [foreign
language spoken], where I kind
of saw, you know, this
possibility of this, yeah,
this kind of looks a
little bit more like me.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay, Mitali.
>> Mitali Perkins: Yeah.
I wanted books because I
didn't like being seen.
I moved to California when
I was in seventh grade,
and I was the only kid of
color in the whole school.
And I was the only kid not born
in the USA in the whole school.
So books for me were a way
to see and hear other lives.
So at school, I was doing
that code switching dance.
At school, I was using
my curling iron to try
to transform myself into
Farrah Fawcett every morning,
that I could miraculously look
like everyone else,
which I never did.
So I think for me, it was
that marvelous ability
that books give us to
see and hear other lives
and imagine other lives, which
I feel is a huge advantage
that we get when we have
to cross borders to read.
And so, I was learning to become
fluent in imagining other lives.
And I think that's how
books served me well.
>> Margarita Engle: I was the
only Cuban-American growing
up in a Mexican American
neighborhood.
And as much as I loved
the poetry of Mexico,
especially [foreign word
spoken], my mother introduced me
to [foreign word spoken]
and I love all the poets
of Latin America and Spain, but
especially the generation of 27
from Spain, who were, you
know, resisting the oppression.
And so, poetry was
very influential.
But I have to say, as far
as being seen in a book,
I was 50 something when I
read Alma Flor Ada's memoir,
Under the Royal Palms, and that
would be the first time I read
something written
specifically about Cuba.
>> Linda Sue Park: Right.
So we're here to make sure no
one else ever, no child ever has
to wait that long again, right.
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> Linda Sue Park: You
know, when I was growing up,
I have a very clear memory of
the first Asians I ever saw
in a book, which was that
Five Chinese Brothers book.
Yeah. Okay, right.
Let's move on.
All right.
Okay. Do you have either a book
or books or an author or authors
who are your greatest influence
or your greatest
inspiration, and why is that?
Is it because of their
craft, subject matter, theme?
I mean, do you have, you know,
authors that you just sort
of hold up as your light?
Mitali, we'll start
with you this time.
>> Mitali Perkins: I just
finished my annual reread
of Little Women again.
And I think I loved Jo much, Jo
March, because she was living
in 19th century Concord,
Massachusetts, and I living
in a traditional
middle-class Bengali home.
But in terms of the pressure
she faced not to use writing
as a way to make money,
if you reread that book,
there's a strong theme in there
about how she chose her vocation
as a writer, despite
all the pressures.
And any of you from South
Asian backgrounds know
that we basically
had three options:
engineer, doctor and engineer.
Those were our three
options vocationally.
So yeah. So she pushed
those boundaries,
and she loved her sisters,
and she loved her writing.
For her, her writing
was something
that she was never
going to give up on.
And that's how I felt
about my writing,
despite all of that pressure.
A refined Bengali woman in that
time did not write for money.
We wrote for beauty.
And so, I think when Jo said no,
I'm going to make money on this
and I'm going to be
independent, I loved her,
and I still love her for that.
>> Linda Sue Park: Nice, nice.
So Francisco.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
I guess, you know,
one of my favorite authors
is Flannery O'Connor,
a southern author.
And I think I was more her life.
You know, she only
wrote two novels
and two [inaudible]
short stories.
But she was a person of faith.
And her works are
infused with that faith,
but you'd never know it, you
know, if you read her work.
In fact, in many cases, you'd
think like the opposite,
you know, just because they're
so undidactic and so powerful.
So you read her books, and
then you put it down and like,
you know, what the
hell just happened.
And you begin -- And
a little while later,
you begin to like notice things
that you didn't notice before.
And I think that the ability
to see things differently is
that power that she gave
me and that I would hope
to emulate in my writing.
>> Mitali Perkins: And
that's why I'm a Francisco X.
Stork fan.
Exactly as you described
Flannery O'Connor is how I would
describe your work.
>> Linda Sue Park: Nice, yeah.
Margarita.
>> Margarita Engle: You know,
I'm going to say Marilyn
Nelson's Carver influenced me
because it was the first time --
And again, 50 something
when I read it.
But it was the first time
I read a verse biography
about someone who'd been
neglected by history.
And that's something I've
really strived to do is to write
about people who've
been forgotten and left
out of the history books.
And Carver has not been left out
as much as some of the people
that I've felt inspired
to write about.
But it was just such
a beautiful thing
that she did doing a biography
in verse instead of in the kind
of formal nonfiction
with footnotes
that a child might not
feel invited and welcomed
to open the pages and go,
ah, this was written for me.
>> Linda Sue Park: Have
you ever told Marilyn that?
>> Margarita Engle:
No, I haven't.
Maybe she'll she this.
>> Linda Sue Park: If
you don't know this book,
I have a special
affection for this book
because it was an
honor book the year
that A Single Shard
won the Newbery.
And it's a heroic
crown of sonnets.
And it's an incredibly complex
form and difficult to write,
and it ends within acrostic.
I mean, it will blow your mind.
So yeah.
>> Margarita Engle: And it
comes across very simple
and [inaudible] understand
for a child reading.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yeah.
It's an amazing book.
Okay. Now, we're going to move
on to our panelists as writers.
And it was very interesting to
receive these books and to go
through them and to read them in
preparation for this symposium.
And immediately, what I noticed
first, the writer part of me,
is that all three of
them chose to use more
than one viewpoint, okay.
So we have alternating chapters
or sections in all three books.
So I thought that was a really
interesting thing they have
in common.
And so, I'd like you to tell us
about your multiple characters
and why you chose them
to be the ones to be seen
and heard in your book.
So we'll go with
Margarita this time.
>> Margarita Engle: Well,
Forest World is an eco-adventure
about biodiversity and
wilderness preservation in Cuba,
but it's also a family
reunification story set in 2015
when President Obama had
initiated the peacemaking
process between the US and Cuba.
And I felt so excited.
And the only way I felt
like I could show this
peacemaking process was
by two children, siblings, who'd
never met each other before.
And that is very
common where one grows
up in Miami and one in Cuba.
And so, even though I've
heard people say they don't
like readings, I'm going
to take just a minute
to read one very short
poem in the sister's voice.
She's grown up in a
rural area in Cuban.
The reason I did multiple voices
was to show the difference
between the US and Cuba.
Now the American brother who
grew up in Miami, of course,
lives on his phone and,
you know, everything's
about Wi-Fi and video games.
And the girl who's
grown up in Cuba,
of course doesn't
have access to Wi-Fi.
In rural Cuba, the fuel
shortage is so severe
that most people depend
on horse-drawn vehicles
or hitchhiking.
And nightfall, the
clip-clop of horse hooves.
Rhythmic flashes from
dancing fireflies.
Around each curve
the rising moon.
Abuelo's long folktales
his stories
of glow-in-the-dark
dogs and magical horses.
My brother's fingers
twitch as if he's longing
to send phone messages
back to his real home.
What was Mama thinking, forcing
un americano to spend time
with los Cubanos, sharing
our quiet isolation.
Thank you.
>> Linda Sue Park: Who says
people don't like readings?
I love them.
I love hearing the
author read, right.
Okay, yeah.
Mitali.
>> Mitali Perkins: Yes.
So you bring the distant near
as a story of one Bengali family
who moves to Flushing
Queens from Kolkata, India.
Gosh, I won't where
I got that idea from?
It's three generations.
And so, I have five
voices, but I wanted
to show how immigration
affects all three
of those generations
differently.
So the heroic generation
really is the first one
that come here seeking really
for the next generation.
They're the ones that
bear the sacrifice,
the loss and the cost.
So that's why, in the book,
the narrative arc
really does belong mostly
to that first generation,
even though she's
in the third person voice.
And then there are the two girls
that are the second generation,
which was mine, the
code switchers.
They're learning how to -- They
know about village Bengali life,
and they know about American
life, in they're learning both.
And they're gaining more
agency in this culture
than their parents
have at a very age.
So that was important to me
because that's really
my generation.
And then there's the
third generation, my sons,
and the question being how
Bengali really are they
and how do we hold onto that
and how important is that in
that third generations.
So people, they'll
identify as Indian, my sons.
But there are 22 major
languages in India
and cultures, all
of them distinct.
So for an Indian
to say I'm Indian,
it sounds like it
doesn't make any sense.
So for them, their
Bengali identity,
really it's getting lost.
So there's a loss on both
of those generations.
And it's that middle
generation that straddles.
So I wanted to see all of
those three generations
and how immigration
affects that.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
So Disappeared has
two main characters.
Sarah is a young
journalist in Juarez, Mexico,
and she's investigating
the disappearance
of so many women
during the time,
during a certain period of time.
And her brother, Emiliano,
is kind of a real go getter.
You know, he's a soccer star
or football I should say,
and has this little
business, a craft business.
And there really like -- The
reason I had like two voices is
because there were kind
of like two journeys.
One of them is sort of
like the journey of kind
of physical journey of Sarah
and trying to say alive
as she begins to uncover
some of the causes
for the disappearing girl
and her left is threatened.
And then Emiliano is kind
of more like a moral journey
in his sort of like the
temptations that happen
when you're poor to try to
make money through drugs.
And so, there was kind of
like both a physical journey
and kind of a moral journey.
And I think I needed, you
know, I needed two voices.
And sometimes I think that like
the two characters are just part
of myself.
You know, Emiliano is who I am,
and Sarah is who I'd like to be.
>> Linda Sue Park: Nice.
All right.
I'm hoping for honesty with
this next one, when I ask you
to describe a typical
writing day.
So my honesty would be email,
eBay, Tetris, open the document,
stare at the document, Tetris.
Okay, right.
So what is a typical
writing session for you?
And Mitali, we'll start
with you this time.
>> Mitali Perkins: I'm
motivated by shame.
I come from a same based author.
So recently, I have the
strong suspicion that editor
and agent have discovered
that about me.
Grace is here, my editor.
And I think they just realized
that without a deadline,
I have the same schedule as you.
So I work best under a
deadline because then, you know,
if I don't make it, there's the
horror of being ashamed, right.
And I work in coffee shops
because I like that buzz.
So there's an app
that you can download
that is called coffee shop buzz
that you can actually
have that on your phone.
>> Linda Sue Parker:
You're kidding.
Oh my God.
>> Mitali Perkins: I'm one
of those annoying
people in the Bay Area.
I shift coffee shops so
I don't get that look,
like get an office,
you know that look.
But I shift coffee shops and
I'm the person that takes
up the space near the plug.
Yeah, that's me.
>> Linda Sue Park: Francisco.
>> Francisco X. Stork: You
know, I should say this
because Arthur Levine
is in the audience
and he's going to -- My editor.
I sit in front of a computer,
and I tell myself I'm going
to do this for two hours
and see what happens.
You know, I don't do words
and quotas and so forth.
I'm going to show up.
And sometimes, it's
a few sentences,
and sometimes I make it
to a page and a half.
And I keep going.
So I work in the mornings, and
then afternoons are for naps
and to-do lists for my wife.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay, nice.
>> Mitali Perkins: Wait.
Who was the write that said
I spend all morning putting a
comma in and all afternoon
taking the comma out?
I can't remember the writer.
>> Margarita Engle: Just
take everything Mitali said
and reverse it.
I need peace, quiet, solitude.
I write with a pen by
hand, preferably outdoors,
and daydreaming is the
essence of my process.
>> Linda Sue Parker:
Interesting.
Because I'm sort of all over
the map, I write my novels
on the computer, but I do poetry
and picture books with a pen.
>> Mitali Perkins:
That's how I write poetry
with right hand too.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yeah.
Sort of. Now the third
section, which is the panelists
as authors, which is different
from being writers, right.
Okay. I'd like you all to share
a favorite story about one
of your young readers
that illustrates our
theme of the power books.
I'm going to start on this
one, my favorite letter
that I have ever gotten
from a young reader.
Dear Ms. Park.
I was absent the day we
picked our author to write to,
and you were the only one left.
[ Laughter ]
So my question for you is,
do you know Gary Paulsen.
[ Laughter ]
But I was delighted that he
had a favorite author, right.
So it doesn't have to
be me, but they have
to have a favorite author.
Okay, Margarita, one
of your young readers.
>> Margarita Engle: I have
received letters asking me
to pass messages along
to other authors also.
But for me, the most
powerful moments have been
when I read a poem that is
very personal, so especially
when I read from my
memoir Enchanted Air.
Very often, a student will
stand up out of the crowd
and read their own poem to me,
in front of their classmates.
This is happened to me on Skype.
It's happened in person.
The most powerful moments have
been when it was a student
who the teacher said,
later, told me privately,
I didn't know that
boy could read.
And he was writing
his own poetry.
And then also, a young girl who
came up to me and recited a poem
about being a homesick refugee.
And she was from Syria and had
just recently come to the US.
So these kids that we are
speaking to and reading to,
they're writing, and we don't
know that unless we open
up to the, and read
our own work to them
and share it very personally.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yeah.
She felt so seen, that girl.
Right. So Mitali.
>> Mitali Perkins:
Well, I just Skyped
with a intergenerational book
club in upstate New York.
And so, the librarian
had arranged a visit.
The senior center
had read my book,
and the teenagers
had read my book.
So they were discussing it
together and they were going
to have an Indian dance
thing and a whole day.
And this is the first
time this has happened
because I gave my
best Skype I thought.
And then they started talking
and they forgot I was there.
I was like this huge head on
the wall [inaudible] because one
of them started sharing, one
of the Indian women there,
started sharing the story
of her arranged marriage
and how she had met her husband.
I had talked about my parents,
who had met each other
on their wedding day.
So she started talking, and
all the teens were just focused
on her story.
But that was exciting
to see that connection.
And I think the other part I
love, even in this digital age,
and I'm a huge social media
geek, is when you go to schools.
Do you guys mind a
spoiler about the book?
You okay? Well, one of the
characters dies in the book.
And every book, every father
in every book I write
is based on my dad.
And so, we had just lost my dad
right before the book launch.
And so, I had to go on tour
and visit all these schools.
And I thought, oh, gosh, how
am I going to make it through.
You're trying to
be professional.
And I went to the school
in Kalamazoo, Michigan,
but 148 eighth graders,
the media,
all the electricity was out.
So everyone is shivering
in coats,
and it was a title I school,
lots of school [inaudible] kids,
lots of immigrants and refugees.
And I hadn't realized the
English teacher had read
the book.
I didn't know that.
She had read the book.
So I shared my story.
And then, a 14-year-old
boy's hand goes up.
And I was really
trying hide my grief.
And I thought I'd
done a great job.
And his hand goes up and
he says, I have a question.
And his voice, you know,
has that cracking 14-year-old
voice, I have a question.
And I said, yeah.
He said, what, I love that dad.
Why did that dad have to die?
And I thought, oh, gosh.
So that was hard.
You know, I'm thinking, man,
thanks for getting me
choked already [inaudible].
Anyway. We are a
very crying culture.
So feel free to join
in [inaudible].
I started crying in front
of all those 14-year-olds.
I mean -- And the best part
of it, I think the connection
that I want to share with you
is that every single faith
in that room had
so much compassion.
They all loved my
dad with me, so.
>> Linda Sue Joe: Nice.
[ Applause ]
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Why do you do this to me?
>> Mitali Perkins: This is
the gift, my immigrant gift
to Americans, everybody cry.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Make them cry.
>> Mitali Perkins:
I make them cry.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Make them cry.
I think probably
I wrote this book
about a young girl who's
recovering from depression,
you know, a day after
a suicide attempt.
And I really wanted to make
sure that that book was,
and I tried very hard, you know,
to various drafts to make sure
that I got it right and that
if it ended up in the hands
of somebody who was like
thinking about what to do
with life, that it would point
them in the right direction.
So the emails that I
get sometimes from kids
that thank me for the book,
it makes it all worthwhile.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, all.
Okay. This question
has a choice for you.
Tell us about the next book
that's coming out for you
or what you're working on now.
So Francisco.
>> Francisco X. Stork: So this
is the first time I'm trying
to do a follow up to the
previous book, in Disappeared.
The kids kind of
get to the border.
And then, so the next
book is their lives,
their undocumented lives
in the United States.
>> Linda Sue Park: Wow.
Can't wait.
How far along are you?
>> Francisco X. Stork:
My editor is over there,
so I can't -- It's
due this summer.
And I just asked him to
define summer for me.
[ Laughter ]
>> Linda Sue Park: Summer
in the southern hemisphere.
Okay. Margarita.
>> Margarita Engle: My next
first novel is Jazz Owls,
a novel of the Zoot Suit Riots.
And it's about the
-- They're misnamed.
They should be called
the sailor riots.
It's about the sailors attacking
Mexican American youth,
their rage triggered by the side
of interracial dancing during
World War II, in Los Angeles,
in my home neighborhood.
And it comes out
did I say in May?
>> Linda Sue Park: No.
May, this May?
>> Margarita Engle: Yeah,
it comes out in May.
And then next year, Soaring
Earth, which is a sequel
to my childhood memoir
Enchanted Air.
It's about my high
school and college years
of the protests of the '60s.
And it's really embarrassing,
and I will go
into hiding when it comes out.
>> Linda Sue Park: I
can't wait for that one.
Okay.
>> Mitali Perkins: I have
my first picture book coming
out next year.
So FSG Macmillan.
It's called Gifts for Abuela,
illustrated by Sara Palacios.
So I'm excited about that.
It's a California story
because it's about our wall
on the border and it's about
a little girl who wants
to get a gift to her
Abuela across that wall,
on the Dia de Los Posadas.
So that is my next book.
And then I am working on
Boy Wonder and Cat Girl,
which is multiple narrators.
I know, it's kind of a --
I'm trying to get into the
Bali woods superhero vibe
of this novel.
It's about two teens from
Boston who go to Kolkata
and are just discovering a
lot about their own stories
as they confront some of
the trafficking that happens
in the city of my birth.
>> Linda Sue Park: Wow.
Well, I'll get in on
this just for a minute.
Next spring, I have a
picture book coming out.
There are dragons in
Western mythology and dragons
in Eastern mythology, and
they have a lot in common,
but they're also different.
So your Western Dragon has wings
and breathes fire and lives
in caves and hoards treasurer,
but Eastern dragons don't
do any of those things.
So this is a little girl dragon
named Gandra [assumed spelling],
whose father is from the East
and whose mother
is from the West.
She breathes fire from one
nostril and mist from the other.
So it' my little
mixed-race dragon book.
>> Mitali Perkins: I want
to give a quick shout
out to Linda Sue's
parents who are here too.
So I would love to
say hello to them.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yeah,
my parents are here.
[ Applause ]
My father got some love a
few months ago on Twitter.
He asked me.
He was visiting and asked
me for a good book to read.
So I gave him Angie
Thomas's The Hate U Give.
And he was keeping a
little list for me of stuff
and phrases he didn't
understand.
So the first question
is, what is this hoes.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. So that was
a fun conversation.
All right.
We're going to move now
to a lightening round.
Now the questions thus far
I did give the panelists,
so they could, you know,
think about it a little bit.
These, they have not seen, okay.
So it's just going to
be a lightening round.
We'll just keep going like this.
They start easy, okay,
and they're going
to get a little harder, right.
All right.
iPhone or android?
>> Margarita Engle: iPhone.
>> Mitali Perkins: I went to
Stanford, Apple girl from 1986.
Francisco X. Stork: iPhone.
>> Linda Sue Park: iPhone okay.
Twitter or Facebook?
>> Margarita Engle:
Both right now.
Mitali Perkins: Yeah,
Twitter I think preferably.
>> Francisco X. Stork: Facebook.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Facebook, okay.
Also acceptable is pass
or I don't know, okay.
R2D2 or BB8?
>> Mitali Perkins:
How can you choose?
That's a terrible question.
I love them both.
>> Margarita Engle: I like
living organism, not robots.
>> Linda Sue Park: They are
alive, aren't they, aren't they?
>> Mitali Perkins: I
want R2 and BB8 here.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
So R2D2 I think.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Okay, the classist.
Okay. T'challa or Killmonger?
>> Margarita Engle: I have no
idea what you're talking about.
>> Mitali Perkins: Pass.
>> Francisco X. Stork: Pass.
>> Linda Sue Park: Good answer.
Legit answer.
>> Mitali Perkins: Pass.
>> Francisco X. Stork: Pass.
>> Mitali Perkins:
What is this question?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Linda Sue Park: We all
need to go see Black Panther.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Mitali Perkins: Oh, man.
>> Linda Sue Park:
So yeah, Killmonger.
>> Mitali Perkins: Terrible.
I feel embarrassed.
>> Linda Sue Park: All right.
Your Hogwarts house?
>> Margarita Engle: You
know, I read Harry Potter,
but I don't remember them.
That was a long time ago.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay.
All right.
Fair enough.
>> Mitali Perkins: Yeah,
Parvati and Padma, right.
So a little bit of
Gryffindor, a little bit
of Ravenclaw, a little
bit of both.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Is Mytherine a term?
>> Linda Sue Park: Slytherin.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Oh, Slytherin.
>> Mitali Perkins: The three
of us are going to a matinee
of Black Panther after
if you want to join us.
>> Francisco X. Stork Geez.
That was a joke, Arthur.
It was a joke.
I read every single word.
>> Margarita Engle: I need
a pop culture tutor please.
>> Linda Sue Park: Arthur,
what do you think I am?
>> Arthur: You are a Ravenclaw.
>> Linda Sue Park:
I am a Ravenclaw.
You are right.
Okay. Desert island album
or recording artist?
Let's start with that end.
>> Francisco X. Stork: I like
Desert Island, whatever that is.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mitali Perkins: These
are complicated questions.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yes, it is.
>> Mitali Perkins:
Desert Island.
>> Linda Sue Park: So in
other words, what one album
or recording artist
would you [inaudible]?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Mitali Perkins: All right.
Do you want to answer again?
>> Francisco X. Stork: You
got to help me out, Jason.
>> Linda Sue Park: The
question was definitely unclear.
That's my fault.
Okay.
>> Mitali Perkins: The
greatest love song of all time,
Let's Stay Together by
the reverend Al Green.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay.
All right.
>> Mitali Perkins:
That's a good song.
>> Linda Sue Park: Nice.
Okay, anybody else got one?
>> Margarita Engle:
A recording artist?
>> Linda Sue Park: Yeah, a
song, recording artist, album.
>> Margarita Engle:
Bennie Marais [phonetic].
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Let It Be.
>> Linda Sue Park: Wow.
Very nice.
Okay. All right.
Last request meal?
>> Mitali Perkins:
That's so easy.
I'll go first.
My mom's cauliflower and
potato curry for sure.
I wish I had some to share here.
>> Linda Sue Park: Do
you have one, Margarita?
>> Margarita Engle:
Expresso ice cream.
That's easy.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay.
All right.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
[Inaudible] with the rice
and beans and hot
chocolate [inaudible].
>> Linda Sue Park: Wow.
Gah-lee.
>> Mitali Perkins: Linda
Sue, you answer that.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Yeah, shake shack.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Maybe you kind of
already answered this,
but I'll ask it again.
An author or book that you wish
everyone in the room would read.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
I'll start.
The Book Thief is one
of my favorite books.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Okay, The Book Thief.
Okay, nice.
>> Mitali Perkins: It's hard.
I'm judging the national
book awards this year,
so I have to be completely
silent.
I can't say anything, right Meg?
Can't say anything.
I did love both of
their books though.
I have to put plug in.
These are both excellent books
so I would say my friends.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
Hold on a second.
>> Mitali Perkins: I've
already been [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
But he's not giving it.
He's [inaudible]
to Black Panther.
>> Margarita Engle:
I have a special love
for Brown Girl Dreaming
Jacqueline Woodson
because I think it's one
of the most important books
of the century, but also she
was writing it at the same time
that I was writing Enchanted
Air, but I didn't know,
and I'm sure she didn't know
that we were doing verse
memoirs the same time.
So I feel like that says
that at this point in time,
people from marginalized
communities are writing
in poetry because -- I can't
speak for her, but I believe
that the harshness of history
requires beautiful language
in softening the blow
that comes with poetry.
I think that maybe
we're facing things
that couldn't be faced in prose.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Oh, interesting.
Wow. I guess if I were
answering, I would just say,
in honor of this event,
anything by Walter Dean Myers.
>> Mitali Perkins: Absolutely.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay.
And this is the last
lightening round question.
I'll put you out of your misery.
It's a good one.
What's on your headstone?
[ Laughter ]
>> Mitali Perkins: It's easy
because it's my Twitter
bio and my Facebook bio.
And it's just going to
say beloved like you.
>> Linda Sue Park:
That's so nice.
>> Margarita Engle: Peace.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
He tried to be human.
>> Mitali Perkins:
That's your Twitter bio.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Great words to finish.
>> Mitali Perkins:
But did he succeed?
>> Francisco X. Stork: I
need your help for that.
>> Linda Sue Park: Okay.
We're almost finished
and ready to hand
on to the next exciting
part of our morning.
But I'll just ask you to finish
by keeping in mind our theme
of the power of books.
You have an audience here of
readers and especially teachers
and librarians who
work with young people.
What one thing would you like
to tell them to take home
to the young people about your
work or your particular book?
Okay, Margarita.
>> Margarita Engle: Just that
verse novels are interactive.
The white space on
the page is not empty.
It contains my emotions
and the reader's emotions,
and you can invite students
to write their own
poems in response.
They can jump in at
any point on any page
and write their own poems.
They can write the
missing voices
because I certainly
can't do it all.
There's the old adage
that a poem is never
finished; it's just abandoned.
The same is true
of a poetry book.
It's not finished.
There's room for them
to come in and write.
>> Mitali Perkins: Do
you want to go ahead?
>> Francisco X. Stork: No.
I'll go. You should be last.
I think it's not about my books,
but I think the action item
that I would say is
to try mentor a young
person in your life.
Just listen to their works.
Help them along as best you can.
And you don't have to
be a writing coach,
but just one young
person that you find.
>> Linda Sue Park: Yes.
Jackie Woodson says she's trying
to change the world
one reader at a time.
>> Mitali Perkins: Yay.
That's great.
I'd say play around with
the windows and the mirrors.
I found unexpected
mirrors in books,
and so will the kids
that you serve.
So I would say let kids roam
freely, but don't limit them
to just the ethnic
or racial mirror
because they're going
to find that.
And I think play around with it
in your collections
and your displays.
So I would hate -- I heard
for many years in my career,
we just don't have an Indian
population in our community,
Mitali, and so that's why.
So I don't hear that anymore.
And I want to keep
that going forward
because our books
are for all readers.
And really, that's the --
I am so thankful too
We Need Diverse Books.
I mean, we've been writing
for years and years and years.
And just to see the attraction
you guys have given our work
because I don't hear
that anymore.
And so, I'd say let your
young readers roam freely.
Find the windows and mirrors,
and just offer them
a feast of books.
>> Francisco X. Stork:
There you go.
Nice job.
>> Linda Sue Park:
Thank you, Mitali.
You've also given me the perfect
ending because most of us use
that windows and mirrors
metaphor, which has been
so incredibly useful, right.
And here with us today, we have
the originator of that phrase,
Dr. Rudine Sims Bishop.
If you want to come
stand up, Dr. Bishop.
[ Applause ]
She was doing this work before
most of us knew it was work.
So we're so honored that
she's here with us today.
So I guess a few minutes break
now before our actual Walter
Award ceremony starts.
And thank you all.
So I had a great time.
I hope you did too.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathie Weinberg: When Linda
Sue said she wasn't going
to do your basic cookie-cutter
diversity panel, I thought,
okay, we're in for a good ride.
And you know what?
It was a wonderful ride.
Thank you, Linda Sue.
Thank you, Margarita,
Mitali, and Francisco.
You know, you have
taken us on journey.
You made us laugh.
You made us cry.
And I'm glad none of you
became the engineer, doctor,
engineer that you
might have been.
I just wanted to say,
speaking on behalf
of We Need Diverse Books,
it's been a pleasure
to cosponsor this symposium
with the Library of Congress.
And we especially appreciate
the assistance and warm welcome
of Lee Ann Potter, the director
of Education and Outreach
for the Library of Congress.
We're going to take
a 15-minute break.
Coffee, tea in the back, water.
Bathrooms down the hall.
We've also set up book
sales thanks to the library
of Congress book sale office.
And please, you know, go
ahead and purchase those.
The authors will very nicely
be signing during the reception
that will follow.
We want to make sure
that they have time to --
We're celebrating them during
the reception, so we don't want
to make them work
the whole time.
So no personalizing and also
no photos for the signing.
And then we're going to
try to do that efficiently
and then let them enjoy
and mingle with all of you.
So see you back here
in about 15 minutes,
and thank you and thank you.
Let's give one more hand for
these wonderful panelists.
[ Applause ]
Hello and welcome.
There's nothing like an unruly
crowd of librarians, teachers,
educators and publicists.
Networking is really great.
And we're going to do it
afterwards at the reception.
So thank you very much
for your patience.
I'm Kathie Weinberg,
and I'm the codirector
of the We Need Diverse
Books Walter awards.
We welcome you to the third
Walter Dean Myers award
for outstanding children's
literature.
It's fitting to start
with an often heard quote
from Walter Dean Myers, whose
legacy we honor with this award.
Reading is not optional.
This award says that children
finding and seeing themselves
in books is also not optional.
We Need Diverse Books was
founded with the hashtag
and 21 people a couple
years ago.
And now, it has grown
to a global presence.
We know how global it is because
one of our founders and the head
of We Need Diverse Books, Ellen
Oh, know who we missed today,
is in Hong Kong at
the book festival.
So I hope she's watching
our live stream.
So everyone say hi to Ellen.
>> Multiple Speakers: Hi, Ellen.
>> Kathie Weinberg: Okay.
Okay, so as an organization,
We Need Diverse Books have
brought positive change
to the publishing world and
the books being published.
When We Need Diverse Books
started the Walter award three
years ago, we had
for our first year
under 40 books submitted
for consideration.
For the Walter 2017,
we had 76 awards,
76 submissions for the Walter.
And for Walter 2018, while
we did add the category
of younger reader, our
submissions were over 180 books.
So that's the beginning
of progress.
We have a lot of thank
you-s to hand out today.
First, to the Library of
Congress for their hospitality,
especially Dr. Carla
Hayden, Lee Ann Potter,
Clay Pencheck [phonetic],
Karen Jaffe
and Sasha Doughty [phonetic].
We could not do this without
the We Need Diverse Books staff
and volunteers.
A big thanks to Caroline
Richmond.
She's everywhere.
She's the We Need Diverse
Books program director.
Judy Schricker, the CFO
and Christine Vallis
[assumed spelling],
the financial manager.
And we couldn't do this either
without events planner
Karen Brown.
And we want the We Need
Diverse Books volunteers
to please stand up.
So all We Need Diverse
Books people
that have volunteered please
stand up and we can thank you.
[ Applause ]
And we want to take a moment to
honor the memory of the legacy
of Walter Dean Myers and
thank his family and friends
for their continued
support of the award.
Of course, the award
would not be possible
without our most talented and
slightly bleary-eyed judges
over there, who have read some
wonderful books this year.
Co-chair Terry Hong is not with
us today, but Maria Salvador,
co-chair, is over there.
[ Applause ]
And judges Derek Ivie, Dora
Maher, Nayantara Mhatre,
Ruth Lowery, and Deb Taylor.
Would you please stand
up so we can thank you?
[ Applause ]
And while we're on a thank you
role, I want to say a big thanks
to the publishers, many of
whom are in our audience today.
Thank you for listening
to We Need Diverse Books
and supporting the
need for diversity
in children's literature.
One last thanks to our
audience of readers,
educators, and librarians.
We could not spread the We Need
Diverse Book word and put books
by diverse authors with
diverse characters in the hands
of children without your help.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
We have a wonderfully
full program.
And to start it out, I would
like to introduce Mark Sweeney.
He is the acting deputy director
of the Library of Congress.
While we miss Dr. Hayden, we're
very appreciative of Mark's time
and interest in the
award ceremony.
Mark is also the
chief of humanities
and social sciences division
at the Library of Congress,
plus serves as a
director of preservation.
Welcome, Mr. Sweeney.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Sweeney: Well, good
morning, everyone here.
The energy in the room
is really infectious.
So I'm pleased to add
my voice to the chorus
of voices welcoming
you here to the Library
of Congress this morning.
As you know, we're here
today with our colleagues
from We Need Diverse Books,
to highlight diversity
in children's literature.
Just four years ago, We
Need Diverse Books began
as a simple hashtag on Twitter.
Today, the organization has
grown from a grassroots movement
into a 5013C nonprofit with
a team that spans the globe.
Writers and illustrators,
editors and agents,
book bloggers and book lovers,
the We Need Diverse Books
team seeks to create a world
in which every child
can see themselves
in the pages of a book.
The Library of Congress
shares this goal.
We are proud to have hosted this
morning's symposium on diversity
in children's literature
and also
to be hosting this ceremony.
Both events highlight
and promote books
that broaden our notions
of diversity and engage us
in meaningful conversations
about them.
To honor exemplary diverse
books created by writers
and illustrators from
marginalized communities,
We Need Diverse Books
established the Walter Dean
Myers Award for outstanding
children's literature,
the Walters.
Walter Dean Myers was
a five-time winner
of the Coretta Scott King award
and two-time Newbery honors.
He was named the third
national ambassador
for Young People's Literature
by the Library of Congress,
the Children's Book Council
and the Every Child
a Reader in 2012.
We are delighted that the MC
for this morning's ceremony is
the current national ambassador
for Young People's
Literature, Jacqueline Woodson.
And I'm delighted
to introduce her.
[ Applause ]
Jacqueline is a four-time
Newbery honor medalist,
a Coretta Scott King
book award winner,
a former young poets laureate.
Her platform reading
equals hope and change,
What's Your Equation, encourages
young people to think about
and beyond the moment
that they are living in,
the power they possess and
the impact reading can have
on showing them ways in which
they can create the hope
and change that they
want to see in our world.
Please join me in
welcoming Jacqueline Woodson
to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Morning.
What an honor.
Okay. I would be remiss to
not do this for my panelists.
[ Applause ]
Y'all will get it after
this afternoon's viewing.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man, that was the
best symposium ever, ever.
I didn't space out once.
It really was the best.
So thank you, thank you.
What an honor to be in the room,
and what an honor to be back
at the Library of Congress.
There's so much love
in the room.
This is place that as a
young person I never came to,
and I never thought
it was for me.
And Dr. Carla Hayden, the staff
here, the energy is amazing now.
And to look around this room and
to see how diverse it is to be
in this moment of We Need
Diverse Books is everything.
It is a dream and beyond.
So I just want to say to the
young people in the room,
hold fast to dreams because
this is what they become.
And y'all are amazing, amazing.
I am still high on the march
on the national walkout
and all the work that the
young people are doing
to change the world and all the
work my fellow writers are doing
to keep us here.
So what an absolute honor.
I have a speech written because
I don't get nervous unless they
tell me that it's
being televised.
So suddenly, the
intimacy is gone
because I know y'all won't judge
me, but the people out there.
I see you.
And bless this.
The ceremony is a
little bit longer
because We Need Diverse
Books is very excited
to present our first
bookseller of the year award.
It is a true universally
acknowledge --
See, see, this is what happens.
And for the, you know, for
the Newbery, for the Caldecott
and the award that's
being given this year,
it's right now called
the Laura Ingalls Wilder,
but there's work being
done to change that name.
You have to write a speech
and submit it a couple
of months beforehand,
so they could record it
and I guess you're not
supposed to mess up on it,
like I'm messing up here now.
But just the idea of having
to write something long
before you get in the room
with the people who
you're going to say it to,
you don't know how the
world's going to change.
I mean, it changes so quickly.
And what you write two months
from the day you give the speech
can be not so relevant anymore,
but this is very relevant.
I do digress.
That was all to just
kind of cover
up my flubbing, the
writing here.
It's a very New Yorker
thing to kind
of knock you off
track for a minute.
It is a true universally
acknowledged
that every diverse
book is in need
of a bookseller to hand sell it.
Of all the gatekeepers in
the publishing industry,
booksellers may be one
of the most important,
as people who both curate
collections and get books
into the hands of readers
who will purchase them.
They have the power to
create book bestsellers,
but more vitally, they have
the power to represent;
meaning that children can go to
their stores and either search
in vain for books that
reflect their world or smile
when they see themselves
on the shelf.
Today, We Need Diverse
Books is proud
to present its first
bookseller of the year award,
a prize that was created
because our organization wanted
to recognize the role that
booksellers have as drivers
of the publishing industry.
No one can read or buy a book
that they've never heard of.
This is our thank you to
the independent booksellers
of our country for championing,
and I might be mispronouncing
that because that's
not a word I wrote.
And I usually write words
that I pronounce a lot.
So, but, you know, it means
for being champions of.
The cause of diverse
books and showing
that they can, in fact, sell.
We do buy books.
The winner of the first annual
We Need Diverse Books seller
of the year award is Sarah Look
of Charis Books and
More in Atlanta.
And I love this bookstore.
I don't have enough time to talk
about how much I
love Charis Books,
one of the early
bookstores that I visited
and the community
that happens there.
So I'm very proud to
present this award.
As the oldest feminist
bookstore in the country,
Charis Books is a local
institution that is proud
and open about its mission
to reflect a wide spectrum
of experiences, lives
and families.
Their excellence
in the supportive diverse
books is evident in the types
of events that it programs,
in the antiracist resistance
and LGBT book list, in its race
conscious parenting collective,
in its community
outreach to librarians
in schools via diversity
teachings and, of course,
in its collection, which
honors all types of diversity.
We need Diverse Books is honored
to present Sara and Charis books
and more with two awards:
one for them to keep and one
that will remain at Charis
Books until the next bookseller
of the year is nominated.
And then you've got
to give it back.
Sorry. Thank you,
Sara and Charis Books.
[ Applause ]
No speech.
I think you have to stand here
and let me take a
picture with you.
Sorry. We didn't
practice that part.
Sorry.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
You might want to
check your luggage.
I've been stopped for these.
And now, we move on to
the Walter awards, right.
Am I? Okay.
>> Any way you like it.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Thank you.
So now we move on to the
Walter awards, and we start
with my brother from another
mother, Jason Reynolds and --
[ Applause ]
Who is here with
his fabulous mother.
Jason Reynolds is a New York
Times best-selling author,
a Newbery honor, a Newbery
honor, a Newbery award honoree.
Okay. You know what?
I'll just drop the honoree.
Make it easy, right.
Jason is a Newbery award
winner, a Printz award honoree,
a National Book award
honoree, a Kirkus award winner,
a two-time Walter Dean
Myers award winner,
an NAACP Image award
winner, and the recipient
of multiple Coretta
Scott King honors.
I think there was
one year you got two
at the same, ceremony, right?
Yeah. He's not messing
around, y'all.
If you going to half step
it, don't step at all.
Reynolds was the American
Bookseller Association's 2017
spokesperson for Indies First.
And, you know, he's brilliant
and also so not hard to look
at [laughter] and will serve
as the national spokesperson
for the 2018 Celebration of
School Library Month in April
of 2018, sponsored
by the American Association
of School Librarians.
We see you ASL.
Jason's many works of fiction
include When I Was the Greatest,
Boy in the Black Suit,
All-American Boys,
cowritten with Brendan Kiely,
As Brave As You, For Every One.
I know that one.
Huh?
>> Jason Reynolds:
It's not out yet.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Oh, okay.
And the track series Ghost
Patina and then coming up,
Sunny and Lu and long way down,
which received both a Newbery
honor and a Printz honor.
He lives in Washington DC.
And just an aside about Jason.
So I have a 10-year-old
son who reads differently.
And he listens to
audiobooks non-stop.
And every time I ask
him what's in his ear,
Jason Reynolds, Jason Reynolds.
But you listened
to that already.
I'm listening to it
again, Jason Reynolds.
But he loves this writer,
as do so many of us.
Congrats, Jason.
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Reynolds:
Hi, everybody.
There's a whole lot of
y'all in here this year.
So I have a few minutes
to say a few words.
First, let me just thank you
to the Library of Congress.
Thank you to We Need
Diverse Books.
I am forever grateful for
the work that you've done.
Thank you judging
panel and committee.
It has never lost on me how
fortunate I am every time
anything like this happens.
I am truly grateful.
Thank you to my mama,
who you always --
[ Applause ]
I like to -- I always
tell people it's important
to make sure everybody who
knows me knows her, right.
I think it's important
to do that.
At the end, you know, all of us,
our lives are sort of fleeting.
And at the end of the day when
she's out of her or when I'm
out of here, I want her
legacy to be as solid
and as perpetual as my own.
It's important, right.
So shout out to my mom.
Thank you everybody
that's been up,
all the honorees,
all the winners.
It's just so cool to be
around such important
and interesting people
doing such fantastic work.
And, of course, the
great Jacqueline Woodson.
She's the only person I
know who is so decorated,
has so many everything, right.
She has all the awards,
and yet somehow it seems
to not take herself
very seriously.
I think there's much
to be learned
from understanding
what it is our role is
and what we're really doing and
that the awards are amazing,
but they don't necessarily
change our character.
They shouldn't at least.
Who we are is who we are.
And I'm grateful for you
for being a big sister to me
in this interesting journey
of the literary world.
Also, my agent, Elena, is here
and my editor, Caitlyn Dlouhy,
both of whom are
just as responsible
for the work that I do.
Now with all that being --
Because you got to do all that,
right, because then
somebody going to be like,
you ain't even thank
the committee
and you ain't even think
-- Okay, okay, okay, okay.
All that's over.
Here's what I want to
say really quickly.
I've been doing some research
and working on this new book.
I can't talk about it.
But I'm picking around
ideas, right.
And this is sort of what happens
in my brain is I have all
this stuff happening up here
and it's moving around,
and I'm trying to figure
out what to do with it.
And I've been really
working on this.
We all know the adage if
a tree falls in the forest
and no one is around to hear,
does it make a sound, right.
We've all grown up hearing that.
I'm not even sure if many
of us have ever thought
about what exactly
is being said.
But we hear that all the time.
I've done some research on it
because I'm interested in it,
and I think it's a
fascinating saying.
And I've been digging around
trying figure out what
that means for my life,
what that means for my work,
what exactly are they
even talking about.
Turns out that thought it is
a philosophical statement,
it actually was a
scientific statement.
And scientists were saying
basically that if a tree falls
in the forest, what happens
when it come to sound is
that the tree hits the ground.
There's a vibration
from that impact,
and that vibration then
somehow travels to --
Y'all didn't make the
announcement [laughter]?
Exactly. The tree falls,
hits the ground, all right.
There's a vibration.
That vibration travels
to the eardrum.
And then when it
hits the eardrum,
the eardrum makes the sound.
But if the vibration does not
hit the eardrum, technically,
then the sound is not made.
That's how sound works, right.
So the scientists were saying
if a tree hits the ground
and no one is there to hear it,
technically it does
not make a sound.
of course, for me, that is --
I mean, it makes sense sort of,
except for the fact that I
think somehow in that argument,
it sort of disqualifies the
idea of the vibration being made
in the first place, right.
So if a tree is a piece of
matter, a tree is a thing,
it's a living thing, a breathing
thing, a growing thing,
once that tree hits the ground,
there's a vibration made whether
someone is there to hear it
or not is of less
importance than the fact
that the vibration is made
and to not acknowledge
that vibration is to
disqualify that life
and the falling of said tree.
Now from a philosophical --
[ Applause ]
Now from the philosophical,
from a philosophical standpoint,
right, which is the
other argument,
which is the colloquial
argument that most of make
when we say this, right.
If a tree falls in the forest
and no one is around to hear it,
does it make a sound,
and we look at that
as a philosophical
statement, right.
From a philosophical standpoint,
I think that perhaps we're not
necessarily asking the right
questions, right.
It's like that seems like just
a limited and simplified sort
of question to be asking about
a tree that falls in a forest
with no one around to hear it,
because there are other
questions, extenuating questions
that we should be
asking ourselves
to better understand the context
in which a tree is falling
in a forest with no
one around to hear it.
For instance, is
the wind blowing?
For instance, was the
tree struck by lightning?
For instance, is there something
eating at the base of the tree,
which makes it a
little less strong?
For instance, are there
termites eating the tree
from the inside out?
All of this would help us try
to better understand whether
or not it matters that
if a sound is made or not
if a tree falls in a forest
with no one there to hear it.
Now let's transpose
tree for child, right.
From a scientific standpoint,
from a scientific standpoint,
if a child falls
and no one is there
to hear it, does
it make a sound?
According to the scientists,
the child does not, right.
According to what
I'm arguing, thought,
is if we say the child
does not make a sound,
if we say that the
child's impact
on that ground does
not create a vibration,
then we disqualify the
life of said child, right.
Now from a philosophical
standpoint,
if a child falls,
does it make a sound?
Again, I think we need
to ask more questions.
Number one, was there
wind blowing?
Was there something
there pushing the child?
there, a force,
an unseen force forcing
the child down?
Was there something there eating
at the child's base, right?
Something there that maybe we
don't know eating at the child.
Were there termites involved,
eating the child
from the inside out?
Was lightening striking
any way in the vicinity?
Was anything on fire?
Was the ground weakened
by anything, right?
And lastly, lastly,
why aren't anyone --
Like, where are the
people, right?
If a tree falls in the forest
and no one is around,
does it make a sound?
the question is, why
is no one around?
Where are the people?
Where is everyone, right?
Because that's the question
that we should be asking,
and that is what long way
down is actually about, right.
Everyone is saying like, oh,
it's about a kid and a gun.
No, no, no, no, no.
This is about acknowledging
the fact that the kids
that we judge every single day
have all kinds of things going
on around them, forces that
cause these kinds of issues.
And it's best for us to ask
ourselves some true questions,
to really mind our own psyches.
This book is not
about any child.
This book is about you.
You read the book.
Whatever you think happens
to this kid at the end
of book has more to say about
you than that child, right.
Do your work to make sure that
our babies have a fair shot.
That's all I ask for.
Shout out to also -- Before I
get off the stage -- I'm done.
But before I get off the
stage, I also just want
to say really quickly to
Margaret Angle, my friend.
It's important, and I want to
make sure I acknowledge her
because at the end of the day,
she could probably explain
that the power of novels and
verse far better than I could.
I think her job and her
role in the position
that she holds is
very important.
And I think she understands the
power of poetry and the power
of verse and its force in a way
that I hope to mature
to someday.
And it's important that
she know that as well.
I appreciate y'all.
Thank y'all very,
very, very much.
Have a good day.
[ Applause ]
>> Jacqueline Woodson: I know.
You can't just drop mics that
are attached to a podium.
So thank you, Jason.
I think it's a good moment
to just bring the
ancestors into the room.
I do this as often as I can.
When you hear the powerful
words spoken by our writers,
I think it's important for
us all to remember the people
who came before us and
how important they were
to who we are now, to
being able to stand here,
and the people who've left this
world but still walk with us.
So if we could just take
two minutes and just shout
out a name of someone who you
want to bring back into the room
or who already is
in the room with us.
I think that would be
fitting in this moment
of remembering Walter
Dean Myers.
That's the name I'll say.
[ Inaudible Audience Comments ]
Mary Ann Woodson.
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Thank you.
Welcome home.
Carole Boston Weatherford.
[ Applause ]
I just appreciate your
power in the room.
So I just have loved your work
forever, and I'm so grateful
to be in the room with you.
Carole Boston Weatherford is
a New York Times best-selling
author and poet.
Her numerous books for children
include the Coretta Scott King
Author Award Honor Book,
becoming Billie Holiday,
illustrated by Floyd Cooper, and
the Caldecott honor books Moses
When Harriet Tubman Led
Her People to Freedom,
illustrated by Kadir
Nelson, and Voice of Freedom:
Fannie Lou Hamer: Spirit of
the Civil Rights Movement,
illustrated by Ekua
Holmes, Ekua Holmes.
Such an amazing book.
And Carole Boston Weatherford
lives in Fayetteville,
North Carolina, and
has been writing
and changing the world
for many, many years.
And I so appreciate you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carole Boston
Weatherford: Thank you, Jackie.
Why'd you make me
follow the philosopher.
After we heard Jason
speak, I asked Eric, I said,
you want to go next [laughter].
Something to start
with, an epitaph.
We've already invoked
the ancestors.
So I'm going to start
with the poem
that concludes Schomburg,
epitaph, 1938.
If this proverb, a book is a
garden carried in a pocket,
is true, then Arturo Alfonso
Schomburg, the historian
and book collector, had a green
thumb and a harvest of pride.
There was no field of human
endeavor that he did not till
with his determined hand, that
he did not sow with the seeds
of curiosity, where he
did not weed out truths,
lies and half-truths,
or that he did not water
with a growing sense of
African awareness and heritage.
If a book is a garden
carried in a pocket,
then Schomburg yielded
a bumper crop,
blanketed Mount Kilimanjaro
with African violets.
If I had African
violets this morning,
I would certainly give some
to We Need Diverse Books,
to the judges, to my editor,
Hilary Van Dusen, my agent,
Rubin Pfeffer, to my family
and friends who are here
with me today, to all of
the librarians and educators
who use my books and other
diverse books in classrooms,
to last but not least,
my frequent collaborator,
Eric Velasquez, who
pitched this project to me.
Schomburg, in several ways,
brings my book full circle,
as does this award ceremony.
Just as Schomburg experienced
a slight at the hands
of his fifth-grade
teacher who told him
that African descendants
had no history worth noting,
I was dissed by an
eighth-grade teacher.
Fascinated with the
Harlem Renaissance,
I wrote a research
paper on Countee Cullen
after having read
his poem Incident.
I was one of only four black
students at my grade level,
at an exclusive Quaker
school in Baltimore.
And I was the only
one of those four
who had transferred
from public school.
When I got my paper back,
the teacher had given me a B,
and it offered but one
comment: did you write this.
Obviously, he had
expected less of me.
Ever since, I have
strived to use my pen
to affirm my heritage
and culture.
When I was an aspiring
children's book writer,
before I had anything
published but adult poetry,
I studied the work
of Walter Dean Myers.
Among the mentor text that
I turned to were Brown Baby,
I'm sorry, Brown Angels,
Angel to Angel, Harlem,
and One More River to Cross.
When I was in graduate school, I
worked on a photo essay project
that evolved into a children's
book, many years later.
It took 20 years to be exact.
My picture research took
me to the Schomburg Center,
to Moorland-Spingarn Research
Center at Howard University,
and to the Library
of Congress prints
and photographs department,
in this very building.
I was looking for images
to accompany my poems.
Instead, I found pictures
that begged for words.
Some were of historic figures.
Others were of everyday people
whose names have been lost.
I wrote poems to
give them voices.
I began right then and there
collecting images and stories.
I'm going to close with a poem
from that book that first led me
to the Schomburg Center:
Remember the Bridge.
Remember the bridge that
your ancestors crossed,
the sweat that was spilled
and the lives that were lost.
Remember the slaves
who raised corn
and cotton keep singing
their songs
so they won't be forgotten, the
Underground Railroad that passed
through at night, the
signs and conductors
that guided slaves' flight.
Remember the soldiers who fought
though they knew they might not
be free when the
battle was through.
Remember the old souls who
handed down tales, the bold men
and women who blazed their
own trails from the South
to the North, from farm
to big-city, with satchels
of dreams and no use for pity.
Remember the bootblacks
who made old shoes shine,
the industrious laborers
who manned factory lines.
Remember the housemaids
who scrubbed dirty floors,
the leaders who spoke
out to open closed doors.
Remember the hard way
the ancestors came,
snatched from the motherland
bound in iron chains.
Remember the voyage,
the capture, the chase,
young warriors who vanished
without even a trace.
Remember the ocean much too
vast to span, long shadows
on shorelines and
footprints in sand.
Forget not the glory of Africa's
past, the temples and riches
that to this day last,
bronze baskets and mud cloth,
pyramids of stone, ebony
statues and bracelets of bone.
The journey continues.
The bridge still holds strong.
Hands reach across water.
Hearts sing a new song.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
That posing for the picture
thing is the most awkward part,
right.
Thank you so much
for that, Carol.
That poem was lovely.
Oh, man. Eric Velasquez.
One cool thing is the children's
book writing community is small,
so we all know each other.
A lot of us know each other.
A lot of us go way, way back.
And when we get together, we
have a lot of catching up to do.
So it was so great to
be reunited last night
and to be able to
gossip about all
that stuff we didn't
get a chance to talk
about and to catch up.
And I want to make a point about
the importance of picture books.
I feel like when
I read Schomburg,
I learned so much
that I didn't know.
And I think sometimes we
think picture books are
for young people.
They really are for
everyone, so.
[ Applause ]
And they're a great way to
teach about the narrative arc.
They're a great way
to teach poetry.
So many of the forms
are so poetic.
So get these books into the
hands of writers of all ages.
They're groundbreaking and
important and world changing.
Eric Velasquez is the
illustrator of numerous books
for children, including
several previous collections
with Carole Boston Weatherford.
He won the John Steptoe New
Talent Illustrator award
for his illustrations
of the Piano Man,
which if you haven't
seen and read, you must.
Written by Debbi Chocolate.
Eric is also the
author/illustrator
of the Pura Belpre Illustrator
award winning Grandma's Gift.
Born in Harlem.
That's so funny.
You know, people born in Harlem
are so the real thing to me.
So I was always so
jealous of black people
who were born in Harlem.
He lives and works in
Hartsdale, New York,
which has the same first
three letters as Harlem.
So we'll give you pass on that.
But his work is mind blowing,
and he is mind blowing.
And I'm so glad to
share the stage with him
and present him with this award.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Velasquez: Wow.
There is a lot of you in here.
Okay. Well, I have my speech.
Okay. I wanted to start with,
for those that didn't see,
the video that I recorded
for the We Need Diverse
Books Organization, my wish.
And my wish is that
in my lifetime,
we'll replace this word,
"diversity," especially
in books, with the
word "normal."
It's a simple concept, you know.
Because diversity in my
house didn't really exist.
I grew up in a Spanish-speaking
household,
but we went to the movies
to see American films
that spoke English, watch
Spanish speaking television,
listen to salsa music,
but we also listened
to the Temptations.
So it was like, you
mean diversity is
like everything,
but that's my life.
So that's my wish for all
of you, lots of normal.
Okay. Now to my thanks you-s.
So I want to thank the We Need
Diverse Book Organization,
as well as the Walter
Award judging committee,
which is named after my
friend Walter Dean Myers.
Thank you to Rubin
Pfeffer, my agent,
for helping this project find
at home find a home
at Candlewick Press.
I would also like to thank
our editor, Hilary Van Dusen,
art directors Chris Paul and
Rachel Smith for their hard work
and dedication to this project,
and to the public relations
team, including Phoebe Kosman
for their tireless efforts.
To master author Carole
Boston Weatherford,
thank you for writing
a glorious manuscript.
You truly outdid
yourself with this one,
our fifth collaboration.
I want to thank the love of
my life, Elizabeth Rosario,
not only for posing as
Elizabeth and Phillis Wheatley,
but also for the
love and support,
reassurance and strength.
You are my rock.
[ Applause ]
Okay. I first became aware
of Arturo Alfonso
Schomburg in the third grade.
My teacher, Ms. Holmes, kept
a poster of Arturo Schomburg
on her classroom wall,
along with posters
of Martin Luther King Jr.,
Malcom X and Marcus Garvey,
that Marcus Garvey
poster with the cute,
the really cool, you know.
He had the uniform
with the -- Yeah.
But what a gift the day she
said to me that Arturo Schomburg
and I shared something
in common,
that we both had
roots in Puerto Rico.
And as she continued with a
brief talk on Arturo Schomburg,
for the first time in my life, I
found a hero that looked like me
and that I can identify with.
I could not wait to get
home and ask my grandma
if she knew this great man
responsible for the library
on 135th Street in Harlem.
[Foreign language
spoken], I asked thinking
that I would just throw
her off with the name.
[Foreign language spoken].
Of course, that man
was a genius.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The same place we come from.
However, aside from
Schomburg's collection of books
and artifacts, she didn't
know much more about the man;
37 years later, while
at the Schomburg Center
attending a performance
of the last poets with Elizabeth
and her good friend Sheena
[assumed spelling], Sheena turns
to me and says, you know,
there are no children's
books on Arturo Schomburg.
You know, you ought to
think about doing that book.
Suddenly, I realized that
this was the handsome man
in that poster that I would
stare at day after day
in third grade, that genius that
my grandmother talked about.
Wait, wait.
I contacted Carol
immediately and asked her
to write me a manuscript
on Schomburg.
That was 2006.
We submitted the project to
several publishing houses
and we were rejected everywhere.
This is just a story about
a man who collected books.
He's so boring.
Jazz him up a little
bit, you know.
Well, it didn't happen then.
In 2014, our now
agent, Rubin Pfeffer,
decided to give it another try.
And after a lot of work, a new
manuscript and new sketches,
Schomburg, the man
who built a library,
found a home at Candlewick
Press.
What a journey.
However, it was through
Carol's brilliant words
that I truly discovered
Schomburg's genius
and his gift to all of us.
This project has changed
my life in so many ways.
I even ended up in the
hospital, didn't I.
I've even met Dean Schomburg,
which is Arturo Schomburg's
grandson,
who is now a man in his 70s.
I've met his daughter
her son Miles.
So that's Schomburg's
great, great grandson.
And so, I conclude with to
Arturo Alfonso Schomburg, I say,
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Applause ]
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Oh, okay.
Awesome. Na na na na na to
the publishers that said no.
[ Laughter ]
Man, I bet you you'll look quite
hard at the next book that comes
across your -- So now
it is my great pleasure
to present the Honor awards.
And I don't have
any bios for them.
So we're just going to roll
with this for the authors.
Caroline, what.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. No, no, no, no.
I know y'all are
tired of sitting.
But I'm going to present them.
Margarita, Mitali and Francisco
have done amazing things
in literature.
And I want to first
present Margarita,
who is our young
people's poet laureate,
and she is doing an amazing job.
And she's, as you
know, the first Latino.
Why does it say Latino?
Isn't it Latina or Latinx.
>> No. It's the first
Latina and Latinas.
>> Jacqueline Woodson: But we're
only talking about a woman.
>> But in Spanish, the
o includes [inaudible].
>> Jacqueline Woodson: Okay.
How about can we say Latinx?
>> You can, but it
gets complicated.
>> Jacqueline Woodson:
Okay, okay, okay.
[Foreign word spoken].
So, okay. Margarita is amazing.
And I'm very happy
[ Laughter ]
to present her with this award.
[ Applause ]
I'll speak for you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I just want to say again
how fabulous you all were
on the panel and how
eye opening it was.
So for those of you who missed
it, that revolution is going
to be televised, right.
So hopefully you'll
get to watch it.
Mitali Perkins has written
novels for young readers,
including Rickshaw Girl, which
is another book that I loved
and continue to love,
and Tiger Boy,
which is a Junior
Library Guild pick.
And we know where she
lives, and we got her bio
when she was doing the panel.
So I am honored, beyond honored
to present Mitali
with this award.
[ Applause ]
And Francisco, who
is just amazing.
And Marcelo in the Real
World is the winner
of the Schneider Family
Book award for teens.
And it's interesting because
I didn't know about it
until my 16-year-old daughter
came to me and said, ma,
you need to read this book.
And I was mad that she knew
something I didn't, so.
Lovely and world changing, and I
am so honored that you're here.
[ Applause ]
So thanks all for being here.
And we are going to
conclude, but don't get
up off your seats yet.
But thank you, thank you,
authors, for changing the world.
Thank you, committee,
for changing the world.
Thank you, We Need Diverse
Books, for being born.
And thank you, teachers,
librarians, writers, readers,
for supporting the
work we're doing.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathie Weinberg: Thank you.
Jackie just did the
unimaginable.
She finished an award
ceremony early.
We are sending her
over to the capital.
She's going to get
things straightened up.
Be okay. Yeah?
Things will be running better.
But fortunately, we're ready
to start the reception.
We'll start.
We'll have more time for
mingling and just being able
to talk to the authors.
They are going to go over to the
book signing table after they go
over with the judges and
have a photo with the judges.
So if you Walter honor or award
winner, if you'd go over there
and just have a picture with
the judges, that would be nice.
And we'll do that first.
Then, they will go over
and they will be signing.
I have strict orders.
They're just going to be
signing and no photos.
And I'm sorry about that.
But we want them to have
time to enjoy themselves,
because they certainly
earned it.
So thank you all.
You've been a wonderful
audience.
And thank you very much to
the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.